let's bring in bill plastique I I know
what is worst of the weekend is the LA
Times columnist around the horn
contributor bill if I told you
Frank Vogel would be the head coach on
Friday if I talked to you what would you
have said I would say what I said in my
column what what yeah it's you know it's
nothing really nothing it's Frank well
when I had to spend my Mother's Day
fielding emails from people saying I'm
being mean to poor Frank Vogel it's not
about Frank Vogel it's it's the whole
liquor situation is such a mess so I
apparently for the best I can gather
best herb I can gather they couldn't
decide on one coach so they hired two
coaches it's sort of like that candy now
and later Frank Vogel for now and Jason
Kidd for later that's kind of what
that's kind of how it should shut down
you know I think they really wanted in
their hearts to hire Jason Kidd but they
didn't think he could pass muster with
his past and with you know he was
campaigning for Luke Waltons job and
there's a lot of stuff there a lot of
smoke there around him so they thought
well Bremen it as an assistant and then
bringing somebody else to keep the seat
warm until Jason Q can get comfortable
here and that's that's the impression I
get and I feel bad for Franco because
it's and you never say you feel bad for
somebody taking a Laker job but it seems
like an untenable situation for him he
doesn't have the respect of LeBron and
by the way you know you see you see
LeBron tweeting out you know never
underestimate the heart of a champion
plagiarizing Rudy tea and all that well
how hard would have been for LeBron to
tweet out nice job hiring the coach or
good job or behind your gum in your
corner Frank or something and he's
obviously on Twitter why how hard would
have been for him to come out and just
support this and kind of you know in
this fire right now and get things calm
to the all-season I mean that that just
drives me crazy to him it just drives me
crazy
well I was surprised that you know there
wasn't any hey got our coach ready to
get started something like that but you
know just play the game even if you're
not thrilled play the game but and then
I started wondering John Beilein just
took the Cavs job he got five years
I he probably said no I don't want to go
to I'd rather go to the Cavs and what's
a better job today cabs are the Laker
well I think I think without question
the Cleveland Cavaliers average I say
have it they have a clap they have a
clue they have a plan they have a guy
running the show there they have they
have a lottery pick a better a lottery
pick I would say Claudia Cleveland
Cleveland cricket is iron Williamson
yeah and you know and you know and then
and then I know Lakers we lucky to get
Jimmy Butler so how I would think that
the Katzenberg jobs yeah I didn't even
know Bill I was available that's what
drives people crazy out here too is that
they just didn't cast a very wide net
the minute tyloo's meant they bought to
that tyloo hiring which it should have
been Tyler all along they just went to
the next guy who would take a 3-year
contract and the guy who I guess again I
don't Frank local those ways going into
adjacent kid but it's you know it is
magic talked about the quote-unquote
backstabbing and whisperin well that's
kind of the reputation of one mr. kid
and uh and that's gonna be a it's gonna
be a tough a tough situation I mean I
don't know you know there's people here
already saying they give over a year and
a half yeah it's taken over but I still
don't understand why tyloo didn't bet on
himself here bill because you know he he
made his good money you know he signed
that five-year 35 million dollar
extension with the cab's after they won
the title and they had to pay him off
fifteen million dollars why not bet on
yourself go in for three years and
instead of being unemployed shows
unemployment over coaching the Lakers
yes because it's such a mess there I
don't I don't blame with me I think he
thought they were linking him to LeBron
forever and that he was gonna you know
there's gonna be an expiration date on
his coaching style there and it would
have elevated him you already you've got
to win you got to win out win out the
younger teammates who really don't like
LeBron and don't trust LeBron how you
gonna win them over if you're LeBron if
you're strictly LeBron guy it seemed
like this strictly LeBron higher you
wanted a chance to show he was more than
just a LeBron higher I think that's fair
and I think it's a fair thing in five
years that's what money Williams got
that's what Luke Walton got five years
yeah I don't know and the Lakers are
making million billions of dollars they
can they could pay the pay month after
three years and
I just thought and so instead the Lakers
hire again they hire a guy
Frank Vogel not connected LeBron but
then they go hire a guy who is deeply
connected to LeBron and so it's they're
in the same situation it's just again I
don't know who's gonna be the first
press conference that's what we're all
wondering who's gonna be at the press
conference in there now if they ever
have if you ever have one Frank Vogel is
gonna be there and I guess Rob link will
be there with Linda Rambis be there will
G be there will Jason Kidd be there yeah
that would be awkward
I'm gonna guess both of them I think
Frank and Jason are gonna be there no
there's no way Dan there's no way that
you can get anywhere there is no way oh
my god I'm in the minority probably I
think Vogel is is a good guy to have in
there now because it's you know it's a
mess but I I need somebody to calm it
down I need somebody who doesn't bring
in drama his resume you know he was
respected with what he did in Indiana
didn't go well in the two years in
Orlando but I do think there are some
positives about him I just think that
Laker fans overrate the job now you know
the fact that guys don't want it or
Monty Williams would choose Phoenix over
the Lakers that would never happen and
and I think the expectation level was so
high no matter who you hired it wasn't
gonna be good enough well I think your
point is good about Frank Vogel being a
good calm face for the organization they
need he's a really good guy everybody
says he's good with the media
he guess he will project calmness but
underneath I don't know what's going on
but now I think the Laker fans I think
they would look at this differently if
they knew who was in charge if they if
they had daryl morey
of course of course I guess his name is
not so great right now because what
happened Houston but you know I'm saying
they had one of those great young
forward-thinking GM's making this hire
that they don't know who to trust they
don't know who to trust now so they
trust nobody and then that's the thing
and again it's hard to trust them when
they hire if they Frank Vogel's your guy
then just hire him don't hire Jason Kidd
to sit there and and and and and whisper
next to him on the bench be the LeBron
whisperer you don't do that did they
raise ticket prices recently yes they
did Ford for you know actually be
because they when a year they saw abroad
after tickets are already sold so they
didn't get any bump from the LeBron
thing so they're gonna get it out I
don't blame em I don't really that their
business side is tremendous it's the
best in town it's what best in land and
optimal in pro sports they saw the best
DVD on the history of pro sports they're
making a ton of money but the thought
here is one more year of this nonsense
and it's gonna start to really affect
the brand and affect the partners and
affect the season ticket holders and all
that so they got one one more year this
thing and I don't know I don't know how
they get out of it I mean I'm not sure
if this duo of Vogel and kid can attract
free agents that's the next thing yeah
that that's that's the bigger point I
think with all of this is initially
because if you get better players then
all of a sudden Frank Vogel looks like a
better hire and if absolutely yeah and
if you don't I wonder about and I was
told this over the weekend bill and you
might know more about this that you know
the partners there's there's there's a
unrest there of you know is there a way
to buy this team from the bus manager
you heard you heard correctly they're
there there's a lot of rumblings from
the aegs of the world and so on some of
the partners and I think they're not
they're gonna wait to this summer and
then wait to see what happens this
summer but obviously she's never gonna
sell herself yeah but you know just as
just don't forget she took over the team
and a crew from her brothers just you
know so the team can be taken over in a
crew that's that's a that that could
happen I don't see that happening until
at least they see what happens this
summer and see what happens next year
they're gonna give her another year but
no people are upset
I mean people there's that silly protest
that had like 20 people and then that
was a joke
the real money movers and shakers and
money people those are the ones who are
quietly protesting and they're upset and
and again I you know she has one year
too few has this summer to figure this
out in next season and if they don't
make the playoffs again and I think
that's all becomes a reality
who you getting their free is Jimmy
Butler now what the expectation level
that's the level of free agency that you
might know it if that's it they're in
trouble because he's not going to change
they know I think there's talk now I'm
hearing you know rumblings about maybe
Kyrie made going to come out here and I
think that would work I think that would
be good with LeBron
but they they need you know I was told I
was told like everybody else they want
one of the case you know clay or Crowley
or Kevin or all those or kawaii but you
know there's no way quiet coming here I
don't look quite evil even Toronto after
yesterday yeah maybe not maybe not but
uh yeah but I think I think the best
thing can hope for is to get Kyrie back
with LeBron and see if that can work and
I and I would support that I think
that's that would be a pretty cool move
but they you know they don't know he's
you know you know how he is
I mean Brian and Brian win horse for
first reporter that but you know I don't
know they I just don't know I don't
think they know and that's the scary
thing to go to this thing in the dark
and again they would help to have one of
the greatest players in history on your
side tweeting out your support and
where's LeBron I mean my goodness you
can tweet out about the Houston goal in
the state series and not tweet out about
his old team I'm sorry I just that's
just wrong
he tweeted out I think about Portland -
I think CJ McCollum is game I think he
tweeted out about that - oh my goodness
just say you're right there you're so
right just say whether you believe it or
not you've got a review got it you got
to live this and if you want to stay
here
and you don't want them to be and you
don't want to be traded and tweet out
this is good moving forward four agents
come on down we're gonna have fun the
party let's get the party started
how about that tweet Frank vocals here
let's get the party started
yeah I mean that would have sounded so
good but you know what if it came from
him it came from him he can tweet
anything just anything any piece support
yes then LeBron by the way the bronze
not going to be at that first press
conference I can guarantee that thank
you Bill good to talk to you so always
you got that's a bill plash Kay LA Times
columnist around the horn contributor
his most recent column Frank Vogel's
hiring by the Lakers prompts a question
are they kidding I don't know if that
was pun intended with Jason Kidd are
they kidding
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app